>>David Wurtz: Let's get started, shall we?
Hi, everybody. My name is David Wurtz. I'm
product manager for Google Web Fonts, and
I'm very excited to talk about Web Fonts,
which was a technology that has the potential
to change the Web. Soon I will be joined by
my teammate Raph Levien as well as Darren
Glenister, who is standing right next to me.
Darren is from a Swedish company, TypeDNA.
So a few logistics before we get started.
We have a moderator page and a feedback page
set up. Please vote and submit questions so
we can make best use of the 15-minute question-and-answer
at the end. We have some official hash tags:
Google fonts, Chrome and IO. For your convenience,
the moderator and feedback link will actually
be at the bottom of every one of our slides
in the presentation.
Before I get started, I would actually like
to take a poll. With a show of hands, I would
like to know if you have used Web Fonts before.
Wow, great. It looks like about 50% of you
have used Web Fonts, which is awesome to see.
For those of you who have used Web Fonts,
hopefully this presentation gives you a little
bit more detail into what Google is doing
in this space. For those of you who haven't
used Web Fonts, it will be a pleasure to introduce
you to the topic.
Here is a quick overview of what we will be
talking about in the next 45 minutes. We will
start with a Web Fonts crash course. We are
going to describe what Web Fonts are, why
you should potentially be excited about Web
Fonts, and why Google is excited about Web
Fonts.
We will then go into Google Web Fonts' overview,
which is Google's offering in this space.
It is available at google.com/webfonts. It
was launched last year one year ago at Google
I/O.
Next we are going to talk about some interesting
trends we have been seeing with Web font adoption.
Finally, we are going to talk about what the
Web Fonts teams at Google has been up to,
specifically three areas: Our efforts to increase
the fonts we offer as well as to change how
users surf and choose and select their Web
Fonts. Second, we are going to talk about
our efforts to make Web Fonts faster and more
efficient.
And, third, our efforts to incorporate Google
Web Fonts into all the tools that you use
every day in your everyday workflows.
Let's jump into the crash course. Until recently,
the state of web typography has resembled
a barren desert. When you are writing your
CSS and you decided you would like to style
a bit of text on your page. You have been
constrained to use the font families that
are installed on Microsoft Windows, which
is the prevalent operating system. This means
we've seen a lot of Arial, Courier, Georgia,
Times, Verdana. We know these font families
very well because they are really the only
ones you can use as true, selectable Web-safe
fonts.
Now, if you compare the visual diversity of
the average Web site to the visual diversity
of the average magazine, for example, the
difference is quite staggering. What you will
find in the print world is that fonts are
used to convey much more subtle ideas and
the variation of fonts in the print world
is staggering relative to the Web.
So we think this limitation is unfortunate
to say the least and it is rather artificial.
But we've seen nice fonts on the Web before.
So there's obviously a way to do it. But we
do consider these things the ugly work-arounds.
You embed text in images which, basically,
means that the content is not semantic anymore.
You are going to have to rely on alt tags,
which not everyone uses. And it doesn't seem
-- it is an abstraction of the content that
you would like to embed in your page. It is
not actually the content.
And if you embed text in images, your text
isn't selectable so it is not copy and pasteable.
And it is not zoomable. So perhaps your users
prefer to see the text slightly larger sizes.
And if you increase the page size in your
browser and you have text in image, it quickly
degrades in quality. If it is actually a real
font, it looks really nice and the curbs are
maintained.
And there is another way to do it. You can
use what's called a Flash replacement technique
which, basically, renders an Adobe Flash object
on top of the object for your text and that
Adobe Flash object contains your font file
but it requires a plug-in. And there is a
slight flash of unstyled text before the Adobe
Flash loads on top of the unstyled text. And
the selection field is a bit odd. You can
tell it is not HTML. So it is obvious the
Web needed a better way to use and select
fonts.
So the solution is Web Fonts. Web Fonts free
of you of the constraint. You no longer need
to refer to fonts that are installed on a
user's local machine when you are writing
your CSS stack. Instead, you can refer to
any font because, theoretically, any font
can be served via HTTP request.
So there's other benefits to Web Fonts. Web
Fonts are semantic. What you type, what you
mark up into your pages is what you mean to
mark up. It is not an abstraction of the content.
And because it is more semantic, there's a
load of other benefits. It is more translatable
into other languages. It is more accessible
to screen readers. It is zoomable. And as
Raph is going to talk about just a little
bit later, Web Fonts can be super efficient
as well.
Google loves Web Fonts. Web Fonts not only
make the Web more expressive, more semantic,
more accessible, more translatable, but they
also make it more searchable. And we think
Web Fonts is a win for everybody involved.
It is a win for you, the webmasters and content
creators of the Internet, because you have
access to a much wider font selection to express
yourselves and you can make your pages more
semantic and accessible.
It's a win for your users because they can
increase font size. They can copy and paste.
They can translate it into other languages.
And it is a win for Google users because Google
Search is going to become better. Google wants
Web Fonts to be ubiquitous, and that's part
of the reason why we launched Google Web Fonts
last year at Google I/O.
Web Fonts is not cutting edge HTML5 stuff.
It is actually supported in 98% of browsers
right now. Now, support for Web Fonts actually
goes back to the days of IE4. It has been
on and off in the early browsers. Back then
it wasn't a reliable choice for webmasters
because not all browsers supported it. When
a browser didn't support Web Fonts, it would
have a very bad failure case where the font
would just not -- your text would just not
display.
But recently in the last two years, browsers
started supporting Web Fonts, which means
right now they are a great choice for production
applications in Web sites.
When I say "the browsers support Web Fonts,"
what I'm referring to specifically is the
@font-face CSS rule. This is the underlying
technology behind Google Web Fonts.
What we are showing on screen here is what's
called the bullet-proof syntax which is, basically,
the CSS you would use if you wanted to host
a font yourself and serve it as a Web font.
And so let's go through it one by one. First
we are defining the font family. In this case,
Droid Sans. And there is the font style and
the font weight. Then we get to the point
where we source it. It can either be a URL,
which is a remote source or a local source.
There are various formats.
Now, it might look like there's some typos
in this snippet, but it ends up this is -- everything
in here is intentional. Certain browsers ignore
certain bits of the snippet. And if you do
it exactly like this, you can have reasonable
confidence that your font will work across
browsers and platforms. But there are some
downsides of using font-face directly. As
we saw, there is a lot of font file formats
that are used. And this is because different
browsers require different font formats.
And if you'd like to host a font yourself,
you're going to have to, basically, take that
font file and convert it into SVG and WOFF
and EOT.
The second is that you will need to find a
host for these font files and one you can
trust because if it breaks, your Web page
is going to look completely different. Now,
for many of you who have a Web host already
set up, this is probably not a huge requirement.
But think about the bloggers, the mom-and-pop
bloggers out there which don't necessarily
have ready access to a Web host. This could
actually be a huge deterrent from using Web
Fonts.
Third, there's CSS maintenance involved. As
the browsers evolve, they support different
font snippets. Just recent -- or font-face
CSS snippets. So just recently, for example,
IE9 actually changed the requirement for what
it would look for in the CSS snippet. And
it meant that for all the webmasters out there
that have used the bullet-proof syntax, they
actually had to go back and change how they
used it so that it could work in IE9. And
there is no telling how many times this will
happen again. So there is a bunch of CSS maintenance
involved when you host font files yourself.
Fourth, there is lots of browser quirks. We
all know what browser quirks are. It turns
out that certain Android browsers break when
you source a Web font via the local selector
that we saw in the previous slide.
And, also, Chrome Frame is another example.
In certain instances, Web Fonts will simply
not work if you are using the @font-face CSS
rule in Chrome Frame.
And, finally, there's licensing complexities
involved. Just because you own a font and
can use it on your local machine doesn't necessarily
mean you can use it on the Web. And oftentimes,
and probably more often than not, the license
to use a font as a Web font is completely
different.
So that's why Google launched Google Web Fonts.
We're, basically, looking to reduce all these
pain points and make Web Fonts ubiquitous.
If you go to Google.com/webfonts you will
be greeted with basically a simple list of
the fonts that we offer.
Today it is 175 open source, free-to-use Web
fonts. And as you browse, you can quickly
discover which ones you would like to use
on your Web sites and then grab a snippet
of code and embed that in your HTML document.
And I am going to show you in detail how that
works later.
We've designed a couple other advantages into
Google Web Fonts. So the first thing is that
Google handles the browser quirks. When your
end user goes to your Web site or blog, we're
going to sniff which browser and platform
they're on and we're going to serve exactly
the CSS snippet that's required as well as
the font file that's required. And so you,
basically, don't need to worry about it. You
can have the confidence that the fonts you
select from Google Web Fonts will work on
all browsers going forward.
Because we do this -- because we do this dynamically,
there is actually a lot of optimizations we
can have, too. And Raph is going to talk a
little bit about this a little bit later on.
Second, there is no licensing worries because
all the fonts are open source. You never have
to worry about being constrained for how to
use Google Web Fonts. We think this is really
important.
Third, there's lots of speed and reliability.
You're using Google CDN, which is very reliable.
Finally, there's lots of font updates, optimizations
and quality improvements. And the message
here is that as we continue to improve these
fonts and we change it in a central location,
all the integrations just get it for free
with no further work required.
And we're also working on some innovative
font-serving features that we are excited
to share with you today.
So meet some of the family. This is some of
the 175 fonts that we currently offer in Google
Web Fonts. Now, these don't look like Times
and Arial. Some of them look wild and crazy,
and that's what we want. We want the Web to
be more expressive and fun and also selectable.
So I encourage you guys to visible google.com/webfonts
and choose some of your favorites, but here's
some of mine. I like Pacifico. This is a designed
by a gentleman named Vernon Adams, who is
a furniture restorer and designer but he is
also a very good font designer.
Philosopher.
Permanent Marker, which is actually designed
by a popular font foundry, font diner, which
specializes in high-quality retro fonts.
And Arvo.
You get all of that font selection for, basically,
30 seconds of integration. The first thing
you do is you include this special snippet
in the header of your HTML document.
And in this case, we're requesting the Arvo
font family. The second thing you do -- this
is the easy part -- you just use the font
you would any other font. So in this case,
we're using Arvo to style an H1 element. And
we are using it right next to Arial and Serif.
It is just that easy. There is no keys involved.
There is no sign-up required. It is just copy
and paste integration.
So far we have talked about what Web Fonts
are. We have talked about what Google Web
Fonts is and why Google has entered this space.
But where are we in the adoption curve?
We are really excited about what we're seeing
here. This is our graph since last year at
Google I/O. And the graph looks very promising
to us. We are seeing up and to the left. It
looks like the growth is accelerating. We
think this is very indicative of the latent
demand from developers, designers like you,
basically who have been constrained to using
a small set of fonts on your Web pages or
blogs but now all of a sudden the restriction
is limited. There really is a huge surge of
demand from the Internet and we're really
excited about this.
So today we're happy to announce that last
week we hit a peak of 110 font requests per
day. And that's across 1.29 million unique
domain names, and we're sustaining about 30%
month-over-month growth.
So 1.29 million unique domains is actually
a fairly small slice of the actively developed
Internet. But what's really exciting to us
is the 30% month-over-month growth because
it if it keeps up it seems like Web fonts
are quickly becoming part of mainstream design
and development practices for the Web.
So who is using Web Fonts? The first thing
is the signs outside are actually using Open
Sans which we are happy to announce is for
the first time available via Google Web Fonts
today. Open Sans is a great font family. It
has got about 12 variants. I encourage you
to check it out.
The official royal wedding Website uses Google
Web Fonts. The specific way they use Web Fonts
is worthy of paying attention to.
They designed a virtual guest book. They are,
basically, using a handwriting font called
indy flower. They have allowed users on the
Web site to basically sign this virtual guest
book in a way they would have signed a physical
guest book. This is something that's really
exciting to us because it is a new interaction
that would have been very difficult to build
prior to Web Fonts existing.
Mahalo, a popular how-to Web site uses the
font Arvo. Sourceforge uses the popular font
Ubuntu.
And to bring in some holiday cheer, the Norad
Santa tracker uses Mountains of Christmas,
which is obviously a font that's popular around
Christmastime.
But the list goes on and on. It is not just
large properties that use Google Web Fonts.
It's lawyers' Web sites, small businesses,
schools, builds, startups like JustinTV, Review
Magazine, ZipRealty, lots of Google properties
like Blogger, Google TV and YouTube use Web
Fonts as well. The list goes on and on. The
long tail is very, very long, and it is as
long as 1.29 million unique domains.
What's next for us? What have we been working
on at Google Web Fonts? Here is where our
three sections are. First we are going to
talk about our plans to add more fonts to
our library. Currently, we have 175 but we
don't want to stop there.
And in this section, I'm going to give you
a sneak peek of something we have been working
very hard on which is the new version of google.com/webfonts.
As we add more fonts to the library, it becomes
increasingly important that we do a much better
job of allowing to compare and contrast the
differences between Web Fonts and truly understand
the fonts that you would like to use in your
applications.
Second, we're going to talk about faster fonts.
And, third, we're going to talk about how
we're integrating these fonts into all the
tools you use.
We're trying to make sure that you -- the
content creators of the Web have adequate
font selection. We want you to be able to
express yourselves and to build semantic and
efficient pages in applications.
We know that if you are in the process of
designing an application for a Web site and
you don't find exactly the font that you're
looking for, you're going to think twice about
using Web Fonts. You might actually resort
to some of those dirty tactics we talked about
earlier in the presentation, and we don't
want this to be true. We want you to find
the font you would like to use.
We are relentlessly focused on increasing
the size of the library that we offer.
We started with 18 one year ago, and we have
175 font families in the Google font directory.
And we're aiming for 1,000 within 12 months.
If you follow us on Google -- on Twitter at
Google Fonts, you will, basically, be subscribing
to new font announcements. I recommend you
do that because it is kind of fun to see the
new stuff coming hot off the press.
In the past, we worked with about 45 font
designers from all over the world. And we're
commissioning these fonts mostly to be built
from scratch and optimized for the screen.
So let's take Lobster. Lobster is a font that's
designed by a gentleman named Pablo Implari.
Pablo is a relative newcomer to the font design
space. But Lobster has amassed 178 million
font views in the last 30 days. And we think
Lobster is a great example of the platform
that Google Web Fonts is providing to font
designers, both established and new to the
industry.
We're really excited about the stage that
we can offer these font designers. Lobster
has, basically, become a brand. Just a couple
months ago I was at South by Southwest and
I saw Lobster on T-shirts. I saw it spray
painted to the sidewalk. So I was impressed
with the way Lobster had spread around.
And as we add more fonts to our library, we're
also very committed to keeping the open source
license. We think this is incredibly important.
And the reason is because there's no telling
what device or platform will be announced
in the future. And we don't want you to have
to worry about not being able to use these
fonts. We want you to have complete control
over their use. Put them in logos. Put them
on T-shirts. Spray paint them to the sidewalk.
They are your fonts just as much as they are
Google's. We would like you to know that.
We would like you to be creative with your
use.
So the V1 directory is currently available
at google.com/webfonts. But what does the
V2 look like? So here's -- I'm going to give
you a quick demo of our V2.
Just a note. This is a sneak peek. We're not
announcing our timeline just yet, but this
is something we are hard at work to productionize.
So what you are seeing on screen here on the
left-hand side are filters. And these filters
allow you to choose whether you want Serif,
Sans Serif, display or handwriting fonts.
You can also choose the thickness of the font
you are looking for as well as the language
you are looking for.
You can search for specific font names if
you are looking for something in particular.
Up top, you can type some custom text. "Hello
Google I/O." And this is really important
if you want to see what certain letters look
like.
Now, what we found is there's different -- you
have a certain idea in mind for when you are
choosing a Web font. You know how you are
going to use it, in a paragraph, as a logo.
And so we designed three view options, and
the three view options are sentence view and
this is the default view. And it shows, basically,
in a string that's about a sentence long.
So you can type a couple more things.
But maybe you know you want to use only five
or six characters. So in this case, you will
put it into letter view. What happens is the
whole interface focuses around those first
letters in your preview text. Perhaps we are
just interested in how IO looks or maybe just
the ampersand, which is an interesting character.
Along those same lines, if you are interested
in choosing body text, you can put it into
the paragraph view. And what this will do
is show you what the font looks like in a
paragraph.
So let's take an example. Let's pretend like
we're choosing the fonts to use on a blog
that covers Google I/O. So let's type "Google
I/O." And let's have an ampersand there. I
will put it into sentence view. And let's
say we want to create -- we want to choose
a heading font. So we want to a really thick
font. So let me go down -- I will choose Black.
And so what we're seeing here are all our
options. And so what I'm going to do is add
I will add a few to our collection. Our collection
is, basically, just a bucket. It is a collection
of things we might want to check out later.
We are not really sure. We are not committing
yet at this stage, but we might like Syncopate.
There are two styles of Syncopate. There's
a bold and a normal, which is great. It might
come in handy.
Coda looks pretty good. Let's add that to
our collection.
And Bevan looks great, too. Now we have three
fonts in our collection.
If I click on the second step "review," this
is where you can get much more detail about
the fonts in your collection. And you can
see them side by side which we found is a
very common use case when selecting fonts,
especially if there's very subtle differences
between them.
And so here we can decide which font would
work best in our application. And so I can
rearrange.
And, you know, it looks like Coda is a little
bit too bold so let's just "X" that out, and
Syncopate Bold looks pretty nice, so let's
"X" out Bevan. Now, if I want more information
about syncopate, I can click the description
tab up top and learn about its origins, as
well as the character set tab, to make sure
that it includes all the characters that I
intend to use.
And so at this point, I'm ready to grab the
code and I proceed to Step 3.
In Step 3, we've realized that in our first
version, Google web fonts, we didn't do a
very good job of communicating the payload
to webmasters, how much font data was actually
coming down, and so we have focused a lot
on communicating that in this last step, and
you'll see, as I check and uncheck the variants
beneath the syncopate font family, we have
an indicator in the right-hand side right
over here that's changing and telling us what
the payload is like.
And so at this step, you're basically going
to ask yourself "Am I going to use Syncopate
Normal and Bold or am I just going to use
Bold?" In this case, we're just going to use
Bold, so I'm going to uncheck Normal 400 and
now I'm just down to a 30K request.
Finally, like we covered earlier, I'm basically
going to copy this code into the header of
my HTML document and I can then use it in
my CSS just like it's a regular font, right
next to Arial and Serif.
And so that concludes the live demo portion
of things.
At this point, I'm going to invite Raph up
to the podium and he's going to talk about
the very awesome things we're doing to speed
up web fonts. Raph?
[Applause]
>>Raph Levien: Thanks, David.
I'm Raph Levien. I'm an engineer on the Google
web fonts team and I'm going to talk to you
about faster fonts. So I'm going to go into
kind of a case study here, kind of work through
an example.
One of the use cases for web fonts is building
a logo. When you look at logos, a lot of logos
are primarily text. Of course there's lots
of other use cases, and what I'm talking about
is going to be good for navigational elements,
headlines, all kinds of things.
And, you know, one of the other things about
logos is it's not -- most logos are not just
pure text. A lot of times they have color,
really cool graphic elements in them too.
So the example I'm going to work through is
a, you know, surfing company. So this is Pacifico
Surf. It's using the Pacifico font that Dave
told you about a little earlier.
And how would you do this kind of the old
way? How would you do this before web fonts?
You'd make an image out of it.
And I'm going to talk about how fast is this?
How much -- that really comes down to how
much is the payload? How many kilobytes is
this that have to be transferred from the
server to the user's browser?
Of course when you do text as image, it's
not searchable or zoomable, but you can still,
you know, get it down to about 7.3K in this
particular case. That's pretty heavily optimized.
So now let's do the same thing with web fonts,
and I mean, you know, it's -- now it's searchable,
selectable, accessible, and if you browse
it on a mobile device, for example, then when
you zoom, it doesn't degrade like an image
does.
But we're up to 50 kilobytes.
And again, this is going to depend on the
use case, how much of a -- you know, whether
that is an advantage, whether that pays off,
or whether it's actually a little bit of a
step backwards for page speed.
So at the bottom of the screen, you can see
the HTML snippet that we're using to select
this font, and it's straightforward. You just
pull it in Pacifico.
And then also in the middle of the screen,
what you're seeing is the inspect element
view, which is a really, really great tool.
If you're not using this in Chrome, you should
be. This gives you a view of all of the resources
that your page is using, how big they are
in kilobytes, and how much time they're taking
to load.
So this is a really good way of visualizing
what -- the performance impact of all of the
resources that use fonts, images, et cetera.
So again, as I go through this, I'll be showing
some graphs that show how many kilobytes we're
actually needing to transfer to get all of
this stuff rendered.
So I was talking about use cases a little
bit. You know, most pages are going to have
a lot of different navigational elements,
a lot of different headlines or whatever,
and if you are doing text as images, then
you have to do a separate image download for
each one of those uses of text.
If you're using web fonts, you can transfer
the font once and have it apply across all
of those graphic elements on the page.
So in a lot of these use cases, one -- if
you build a big site, not just the one-image
use, then web fonts -- even just the simplest
application of web fonts -- can be a huge
performance win.
So we're always looking, how can we make this
faster? I mean, Google is obsessed with speed.
The faster the pages run, the better the user
experience is, the better conversion rates
are, so we want to do everything we can to
make that faster.
And especially for mobile. So I'm going to
talk about that a little bit too today.
When you look inside of a font, you find that
a little bit more than half of it typically
is in the glyph shapes, the metrics, what
actually makes the font the font, and almost
half of it is metadata that's used only for
making Windows rendering better.
Well, that's really important, and in fact
we've been doing -- in the last year, we've
been doing a lot of work kind of quietly a
little bit behind the scenes to make Windows
rendering better quality. So almost all of
our fonts today have high-quality Windows
metadata to improve that hinting.
But if you're on a mobile device, that's data
you're transferring over the line that you
really don't need.
So in February of this year, we rolled out
an optimization that detects when you're on
a Mac, an Android device, or a iOS device
-- a iPhone or an iPad -- in other words,
a device that doesn't need that extra metadata.
When we detect that, then we serve an optimized
version of that font on the fly that, in this
case, brings the request down to 29K, which
is a pretty good improvement.
And you'll notice the HTML snippet that you
used to select that font is exactly the same.
You didn't have to change anything in your
page. All of the users of the Google Font
API got this optimization completely for free.
And that is something that would not be possible,
using the pure CSS at font face. You get that
because of the dynamic work that the Google
Font API is doing behind the scenes.
So that's bringing the request down to 29K.
A nice -- you know, something that really
is practical, even if you're building sites
that are optimized for mobile.
But of course we weren't satisfied there.
Why are we sending the entire font to build
this logo when we're only using 10 characters
out of it?
What if there was some way that we could ask
for just the letters out of this font that
we're actually using?
So I'm really excited to introduce today the
text equals parameter to the Google web fonts
API.
And so you can see it at the bottom, that
we add to the request the exact text that
we're going to render. Actually, you can use
the letters. They don't have to be in order
and they don't have to contain duplicates,
but here it's easy to see what we're doing.
And now the font that you get back is 4.6K.
I mean, it's incredibly tiny. You can use
this on a mobile device, and it's effectively
instant. Except 4.6K is the version that we
give to Windows, so you can see in the chart
the amazing, you know, reduction in size that
we were able to get.
But you can actually do both of the optimizations
to get there, and again, this is done with
the same HTML snippet. You don't have to do
anything special to get the mobile Android
and iOS optimization.
And when both of these optimizations are applied
together, it brings the request down to 2.8K,
which is just, you know, amazing in terms
of how fast that will transfer over the wire.
So in this case, it's even significant improvement
over an optimized image for that page.
So there's lots and lots of benefits of using
this feature. It's fast. Especially for mobile.
And we heard a lot about Android this morning.
Mobile web is a huge part of the web, and
growing fast, and so we really want to optimize
sites for mobile web as well.
You can use one font. You can use one text
equals request for all of the text on your
page. So if you've got lots of navigation
elements or menus, you can combine all of
that into one request to the Google Font API,
get one font that renders for all of those
uses, whereas images would require one image
per use on that page.
And another thing that we're really excited
about, going forward, is that this technique
works very well for international fonts. Multilingual
fonts can be huge.
A Chinese or Japanese font can get into multiple
megabytes. So we're -- all of these -- the
text equals feature works on all the international
fonts in the Google Font -- Google web font
service as well, and we think this is really
key to get worldwide adoption of web fonts.
So I want to step back a little and just go
through all of the things that we're doing
to make web fonts fast.
In addition to the features that I talked
about before, the size optimization for mobile
and Mac and the text equals feature, we're
doing a lot of innovative things behind the
scenes in our serving infrastructure. We're
setting maximal caching of those fonts. We
can do that because they're open source. There's
no peg 8 that we need to put in place, so
we can go completely floor to the -- you know,
foot to the floor to get those fonts as fast
as possible, and that includes our caching
strategy. That includes across sites.
So if somebody has navigated to a site that
uses a Google Font and then they navigate
to your site that uses that same font, that
font will already be in the user's cache and
there isn't even a network request to check
whether it's in the cache. It just renders
instantly in that case. That's one of the
reasons we're so excited to see the incredible
increase in adoption that Dave was talking
about earlier.
The more popular the Google Font service becomes,
the faster it's going to be.
We, of course, use maximal compression on
all of our fonts, and today that's including
the WOFF format on all modern browsers. On
browsers that don't support it, we use different
forms of compression, but we use the maximum
compression that's available.
I talked about the optimizations, the size
optimizations for mobile, text equals, and,
you know, don't forget that everything is
being served from Google's worldwide infrastructure,
so we've got data centers around the world
and you'll get the fonts served to the user
from their nearest data center, no matter
where they are and no matter where the site
developer is.
So, you know, we're hard at work. That's a
big part of what we do is building the fastest
infrastructure for serving web fonts that's
possible.
But the integration for you is easy and quick.
The 30 seconds that you saw is all you need
to integrate the Google web fonts and you
get all of the benefits, including all the
speed, as part of that.
So next I'd like to talk about web fonts in
more places.
You already see web fonts integrated into
Drupal, WordPress, and Google properties such
as blogger.
The Drupal and WordPress plug-ins were done,
you know, by independent developers on their
own initiative, and to get the list of fonts,
they use a combination of, in some cases,
hard wiring in the list or in some cases scraping
it off of our HTML.
And so we figured there must be a better way
to do this, to get a fresh, up-to-date list
you know, with all the fonts that we're launching
every week now, you know, that list is growing
fast.
And so we're announcing currently in a trusted
tester status the Google web fonts developer
API, which gives a fresh up-to-date list of
those fonts.
So if you're a developer and you want to put
Google web fonts in the menu of any of your
products, come see me afterwards or send me
an e-mail and we'll get you listed in the
trusted tester program, and of course we'll
see this rolling out soon and benefiting all
of the users.
We also want to see it integrated into more
tools. A lot of web developers use the Adobe
Creative Suite -- In Design, Photoshop -- and
so we want to -- you know, we want to see
Google web fonts used everywhere, including
in these tools, and so I'm really happy to
introduce to you Darren Glenister from a Swedish
company, TypeDNA, and he'll be talking to
us about the tools that his company is developing
to get Google web fonts in products, including
the Adobe Creative Suite.
[Applause]
>>Darren Glenister: Thank you, Raph. My name
is Darren Glenister. I'm development director
for TypeDNA. TypeDNA is a Swedish company
that specializes in font technologies.
We create tools that actually analyze characteristics
of fonts and help designers choose and use
fonts. TypeDNA's core product is a unique
font manager that works stand-alone and also
directly in Adobe CS5.
I'm going to start by showing you a quick
video that highlights TypeDNA's features.
[Video.]
>>Darren Glenister: So over the past few months,
we've been using the Google web font developer
API to enhance our CS5 plug-ins, and so today
I'm proud to announce the inclusion of Google
web fonts direct inside Photoshop In Design
Illustrator via TypeDNA.
So this here is TypeDNA running in Photoshop.
Many of you probably use Photoshop to mock
up web pages or applications. I will show
you how TypeDNA gives direct access to Google
web fonts and how they can be applied to this
example web page template.
By default, TypeDNA shows fonts from a hard
drive as you can see listed you here. To get
access to the Google web fonts, I click the
web fonts channel here, and then select Google.
Now, here I have a list of Google web fonts.
TypeDNA's tools are available to me to help
me find the font I want.
Tools that TypeDNA provide are Similarity,
for finding similar fonts, Harmony for mixing
fonts, Smart Choice for suggesting fonts,
and attribute filters for detailed filtering
by weight, width, italic angle, and optical
size.
And all of these tools work by character analysis
and do not use any metadata.
For my design, I'm going to pick two fonts.
Firstly, a headline font and secondly a body
font.
Let's start by finding a headline font.
I want to use something quite heavy, but rather
than scrolling through hundreds of fonts,
I'm just going to use TypeDNA's attribute
filters.
All I need do is select the weight filter
and "very heavy."
And as you see now, the results are filtered.
From these results, I personally quite like
Candal but I still don't think it's actually
heavy enough so what I'm going to do is use
the TypeDNA Similarity function to find more
fonts like Candal Regular. So now I'm shown
a list of similar fonts. And again, this is
all by characteristics.
So what I'm actually going to do is use -- I'm
going to pick Paytone One Regular as the font,
and as I do is double-click here and it installs
it locally on my machine and it's ready to
use. And as you can see here as well, I actually
have the code that I need to add to my HTML.
I'm going to find a second font now. I'm going
to find a complementary body font and I'm
going to do this by using TypeDNA's Harmony
feature. So as I have Paytone One selected,
all I do is collect Harmony and then click
Harmony body and then TypeDNA analyzes the
characteristics of Paytone 1 and makes suggestions
of body fonts that work well with that headline
font. So I'm actually going to go for Arvo
Regular as my body font and again, all I do
is double-click and this time I'm going to
as to view the installed fonts. So now I get
the fonts that I've actually installed on
my machine that are suitable as web fonts.
And now I'm outside of the Google web font
directory but I still have access to the CSS
code required to use the font.
So to apply these fonts in my document, all
do you is go back to my document, I pick the
headline, apply Paytone, then I pick the body
and apply Arvo Regular and as you can see,
it's very simple to bring Google web fonts
direct inside the CS suite via TypeDNA.
I just want to show one more example of a
tool that we have. This is a page that I created
earlier, and this is -- this is a font I actually
chose, and this font is a font that's on my
system. I know it's not available as a web
font, so what I'm going to do is use TypeDNA
to suggest to me similar Google web fonts
that are available.
So I go into my local directory. I click the
plus here, and then ask to tell me what the
current font is in the document, which is
Abadi MT Condensed. I just click here and
then click the similar web fonts body which
then takes me into Google and it makes suggestions
of similar Google web fonts.
I'm going to take the top match here, double-click
to install, view, and then swap it out and
as you can see, there was hardly a change,
but that font is free to choose, direct from
the Google web font directory. So that gives
you an idea of what TypeDNA have been doing
with the Google web fonts directory, and over
the coming weeks we'll be releasing tools
you're going to use directly online. For example,
we'll be releasing some tools that reads all
the fonts from your hard drive and you can
use similar fonts from the Google web fonts
directory. I thank you for your time and pass
you back.
[ Applause ]
>> David Wurtz: Thanks very much, Darren.
So let's recap. We first started with a web
fonts crash course where we learned what web
fonts are and why you should potentially be
excited about them. We then talked about Google
web fonts, which is Google's offering in the
space and is available at Google.com/webfonts.
We then talked about Google trends. The exciting
trends we've been seeing with web font adoption.
And, finally, we went into more detail on
what Google web fonts team is working on,
specifically, our plans to add more fonts
to our library and to redesign the front-end
browser experience for those fonts, to make
web fonts faster, and to integrate them into
all the tools that you use every day. So,
with that, we'll go to questions.
>>> Hi. Have you thought about using -- getting
some mathematical fonts? Mathematics is very
font-intensive. I'm involved with an open
source math project called mathJax, which
is a JavaScript engine for displaying math.
And it's heavily dependent on fonts, and the
subsetting, the caching, all the things that
you mentioned are even, you know, huge advantages
in this case. Because you're always working
with huge numbers of symbols in the font but
any one page will only use a small subset
of it.
>>David Wurtz: So we hear a lot of requests
like this. There's icon fonts. There's symbol
fonts. There's mathematical fonts. The truth
is we're not prioritizing it at the moment,
but we definitely recognize there's a lot
of opportunity to do this.
>>> You could actually go a long way by supporting
one font. There is the sticks font, which
is an open source font that a bunch of organizations
and publishers got together and designed.
And most, you know, online math is starting
to use that font.
>>David Wurtz: That's great to know. Thank
you. I'm going to take one from our moderator
page.
"What are your thoughts on served web fonts
and their inability to render 100% properly
on Windows 7 PCs? Some fonts look great, and
some are just plain unusable."
>>Raph Levien: So this is a really interesting
question. First of all, we're doing a lot
of work. We're going over the fonts that are
currently in the directory, and we're commissioning
new fonts. We're doing a lot of work to improve
the quality of Windows rendering. It's not
really just Windows 7. It's all versions of
Windows that have two rendering engines. There's
GDI, and then there's the new rendering engine
that's used, among other places, by Internet
Explorer 9. And the new rendering engine is
actually capable of a lot better quality.
And we're again doing work on Google fonts
to make the best use of this. We're aware
of this and definitely making a lot of progress
on it.
>>> Great to hear about your progress over
the last year. 1,000 new fonts sounds wonderful.
Good work. I have one question about the markup
that you generate. You say you generate CSS
code, but you're not clear you generate HTML
code -- right? -- with CSS kind of tucked
in there.
>>David Wurtz: Right.
>>> In my -- aesthetically, I'd rather use
CSS code. I think it looks better. It sort
of puts the presentation into one container
and the HTML into another. Others may disagree.
And I know you also generate the CSS code
if you go into advanced techniques. Would
you consider switching, or is there a reason
you choose to generate HTML inside CSS?
>>Raph Levien: Yes, there is a reason. And
it's, basically, the import rule for CSS actually
causes some blocking that you can serialize
the loading of the different CSS elements
on some especially older browsers. So, if
you are designing primarily for newer modern
browsers, then doing it completely in CSS
is a great option.
>>David Wurtz: Let's take another one from
the moderator.
"Will web fonts work with any potentially
offline solution, such as the mobile web app?"
>>Raph Levien: That's a great question. I
really don't have an answer for it. It's kind
of an emerging space.
>>> You mentioned that the fonts are open
source. Which license is being used?
>>David Wurtz: We actually use a variety of
licenses. The most common one is OFL.
>>> Does that allow for derivative works?
>>Raph Levien: Yes, it does. Both of the primary
licenses we use, Apache 2 and SIL open font
license, do allow for derivative works. There's
some -- you have to do attribution. And there's
some rules about, you know, what you name
the fonts that you have to kind of respect
the wishes of the font designer around the
names of those derivative works. But you're
free to mix them all together, you know, add
your own characters, basically, do anything
you like.
>>> And then, related to that question, the
gentleman talked about the math font that
is available. Is there a model for people
to contribute fonts in your repository at
this point in time?
>>Raph Levien: We work with lots of font developers.
There's no kind of -- you know, self-serve
mechanism --
>>> So no.
>>Raph Levien: -- now. But, if you're developing
fonts, we probably want to talk to you.
>>> All right. Thanks.
>> David Wurtz: I'll take another one from
the moderator.
"Great job on the optimizations. Is it possible
to reduce HTTP requests as well when using
multiple web fonts?"
So the answer is yes. That's exactly what
the version of Google version 2 web fonts
will do. It's support in v1 as well. Basically,
in the snippet that you include, it's possible
to just request multiple fonts in that one
HTTP request. But the v2 makes it really simple
for you to understand the payload differences.
And, as you uncheck and check the variants
that they're using, you'll see the snippet
actually change in realtime.
>>> Just wanted to preface my question with
the statement that I have a company I work
for. We're real happy with Google font API
and what it's been able to do for us. However,
as a digital agency, we're involved in fairly
highly creative works. And we've used Typekit
and others because they're integrated with
several popular and vast font foundries. And
the fact that we pay for it -- pay for that
service gives us that ability to access those
-- that large library of fonts and appreciate
what you're doing with adding more fonts to
the library. But the fact that you plan to
stay free, I gather, seems like that it might
prohibit you from getting some more of those
other foundries involved or, I guess, better-looking
fonts.
>>David Wurtz: First of all, I want to say
we actually love the fact that there's many
different options in the space. So, to remind
you why Google is in the space, we want to
see web fonts as ubiquitous technology. The
fact that Typekit is doing amazingly well
is really great for Google as well as it is
for the Typekit folks. I think it's true that,
if we decided to do some type of commercial
offering, there would be lots of foundries
that would be more willing to hand their fonts
over to our serving infrastructure. But what
we're finding and what our goals is is that
we want to grow the pie. We want to make sure
that the folks that are just the casual bloggers
have sufficient access to high quality fonts.
And we'll fill the market from below, make
a solid foundation. And then there could be
other commercial offerings like Typekit, which
will partner directly with the who's who of
the font industry and bring really high quality
fonts to users. So we see it working synergistically,
actually.
>>> When I advocate people using Google webkit
web forms, I say they should use JavaScript
API because it allows you for to use fallback
font to have another font size. Like, when
you fall back to Arial and you have a font
that looks great in 300 pixels, you don't
want to have 300 pixel Arial on the page.
So can the previewer also generate Java code
for me as an extra option? Because that would
be something to promote that feature because
it's much more bulletproof than just putting
the new font in.
>>Raph Levien: That's a great question. Today,
no. Certainly, as we develop version 2 of
the directory, that's one of the things we're
going to be look at. You're absolutely right.
JavaScript API has some real advantages to
controlling the fallback fonts with the way
the fonts stage in a lot better. In the case
where the font is, you know, is slow to load
or if the Google web font server goes down,
which it hasn't yet, by the way, you have
to plan. You have to prepare.
It's more complicated to integrate the JavaScript.
And so, you know, it's there as, basically,
a feature for more advanced developers. There's
definitely more that we can and should do
to advocate it and to make that adoption simpler.
So thanks for bringing that up.
>>David Wurtz: Let's take another one from
the moderator. "Is there some plans to bring
web fonts to Android?" The good news is that
Google web fonts do work in the Android browser,
so, in a way, they're already there.
>>Raph Levien: 2.2+.
>>> I think I tried it in one browser. I forget
which one. Does text shadow and all that stuff
work on the web fonts?
>>David Wurtz: It does. Yeah.
>>> It does. Maybe it was just the browser.
>>> How is the support for international characters
in the current -- in the family of web fonts
that are in the Web site?
Do they have an extended character set, or
do they mostly support Latin and Western European?
>>Raph Levien: Another great question. We've
been slowly building out the range of international
character set. So we have -- most of the fonts
are supporting Latin. A growing number of
the fonts are also supporting Cyrillic and
Greek and a few other, like, Latin extended
ranges. There are a few others. We actually
have a lot of Kumar fonts in the directory.
For the more complex scripts, we're working
with the browser manufacturers, of course,
including Chrome, to really make the support
for those scripts bulletproof. One of the
things that we really try to do in the Google
web fonts is make all of our fonts rock solid.
We don't want to have anything in there that
only works a little bit or only works in some
cases. So we're really trying to make the
support for that 100% rock solid before we
roll it out. But it is definitely important
for Google to make these fonts worldwide,
all languages. And so that's what we're working
on.
>>> Thank you. Very good.
>>David Wurtz: Let's take one more question.
>>> With regard to performance, if I have
a page and I load A, B, C and a second page
loads D, E, F and I get to a third page and
I load A, C, F, what happens on that third
page?
>>Raph Levien: Well, so that's a great question.
And we're -- we are going through our data
and trying to figure out how to optimize those
cases. So, you know, it might load a different
font. Or we might be able to figure out how
to aggregate and optimize those. So that's
one of the -- again, going forward, one of
the things that we're going to try to figure
out what is the most optimized way that we
can respond to those requests?
>>David Wurtz: All right. Thanks, everyone.
If you have any more questions, feel free
to join us up here. We'll be hanging out.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]